let's go now to fema administrator
deanne criswell she joins us from fema
headquarters in washington uh
administrator good morning to you
every minute the sun gets a little
higher you'll learn a little bit more
about the damage what are you seeing
what are you hearing so far
good morning tony yeah we are starting
to see more damage now that the sun has
come up i've been in touch with my
regional administrator who is in baton
rouge both last night and this morning
and we're getting reports of significant
structural damage across the area
potentially some buildings that have
collapsed
and as you just heard several people
that are calling for assistance to help
them get out
we're going to have a long road over the
next few days as we try to identify
where people may be and people do need
to be prepared to stay
put for about 72 hours we're going to
get to you the state and the local first
responders are going to get to you as
quickly as they can
and where would you say is the worst
damage that you're aware of so far and
we unfortunately have heard there is one
fatality already tied to the storm are
you getting more information on that
front
we don't really know where the worst
damage is going to be but what i can say
is that this was not only just a
category 4 hurricane as you heard it
stayed a category 4 for several hours
we're going to learn more about what
those where those damages are where the
most significant damages are as we get
out and do assessments today
one of the big concerns in the aftermath
of a storm like this is power being
restored i was down there for a previous
hurricane and it was days before people
were able to get back to normal what is
your expectation what should people down
there expect in terms of when power may
be back online
yeah there's over a million customers
right now without power i think people
should be prepared for several weeks
before the full power restoration comes
on you know and we're not going to be
able to tell you exactly where it's
going to come on first and so people
need to be prepared it's going to be
weeks before we get all of it restored
wow several weeks since a long time
dozens of shelters were set up for
people those have generators what are
you hearing about shelter capacity are
people showing up or is still too early
i know there were people in the shelters
last night
the american red cross such a great
partner of ours
i believe last night some of the numbers
that were reported are just over 2 000
but we expect that number to grow as
people now see that they can't get back
into their homes we know that there's
going to be an increase in the number of
people that are seeking some temporary
shelter the gulf of mexico that whole
perimeter
on the southern coast is key to the oil
and gas industry in this country
what are you hearing about the security
and safety of those workers and also
those facilities
i know that they did put their
evacuation and their
impact plans in place yesterday i don't
have any information yet on the impacts
again i think we're going to start to
see what those impacts are as we go
through the morning today
all right administrator chris well thank
you very much
thank you tony